thank you for the invitation and glad to
give a presentation about the
computerization meets title as come
division meet social media social
network actually we were in this slide I
will introduce the works that we have
done in pencil a lab and these
techniques is one of some research
topics in our labs and this topics can
be shifted with with the product of our
company ok first I will give an
introduction of brief introduction about
our company so I'm not sure whether have
you heard tension before actually tenzin
tourism one of the largest internal
company I think that I can say that not
only in men of China either all over the
world so this is the one of the largest
Internet company and the democra
capitalized is five hundred billion US
dollars so I think that even comparable
with Facebook oh you know even larger
than Facebook readings sometimes and
also we have several products and
several several trends for the most
important one is social social net
social media is social network so we
have WeChat and this is which allowed
also we call the whishing in Chinese so
which had and also QQ so this is two
types of Instant Messenger something
like the Facebook and it's going I mean
us and also we have games and the
Tencent games is the largest I think
that the number one game company we have
the REM U of U in the USA with over 10
billion u.s. dollars in 2016 and we have
several you know maybe someone is
familiar with supercell which we have
already acquired 80 percentage of shares
so this is we think that we are the
largest weak we are the owners or the
eight percentage share the owners of
Isuzu and also we have some content
working on uncounted or something like
that in some video this is something
like the Netflix and also the tensor
music is something is modify and we have
the largest copyright to you know Menem
China for the music ones and also we
have Tencent news so it about common
content and also because the tension is
them one of the largest Internet company
so we have the other
you know the business such as a finance
or insurance or something like that
these are all based on Internet okay so
this is a man instruction about
retention and in the next I will give a
brief instruction about Tessa Allah that
I were I'm now in so Tanzania Arab have
actually is funded in 2016 and we have
two locations while in Milano China in
Xinjiang manam China and a wire office
is in Seattle
USA okay actually we have for research
topics under the center is the
Machinery's we focus on the basic
machine learning the machine learning
series and also la la scale machine
learning platform and as well as the
infrastructures and based on the machine
learning part we have three application
research areas come division language
and speech and we would like to
something actually from for this we
focus on the areas of this application
and we do some well reinforce learning
for the decision and also generation for
the creation and also we would like to
maybe make some cocoa nations for the
ANA standing of the world of the humans
of the world okay so in the following in
the following of this lecture I will
give an introduction about
computability the work that we have done
in computer vision and we from the low
level image and image video processing
to the meta level image video analysis
and the human that defines the image and
the video understanding okay and we have
done several works here subtract the
start transfer enhancement and solution
under the hazing I would like to select
some topics that have already this
technology we have already got paper
publish and also shifted to the product
and the segment is the image analysis we
focusing we I will try to introduce some
pose estimation and is a video interest
attractiveness and video classifications
and also in last for the even hard
deeper learning in a different standing
of the videos I will give some
instructor images I will give some
instruction about captioning and also
the natural language would be the
localization okay for
this is a video start transfer they say
they'll give a brief image about the
video star transfer and we have the
videos and we have a style image and we
perform the star transfer we would like
the study made videos to preserve to
preserve the content of the video
sequences and also it will borrow the
style information from the style style
image and the most important this is
very popular in 2016 at the Prisma but
nowadays for the video we have there we
are the first work from working on the
videos for the video this is the most
important thing to maintain the temporal
consistence between adjacent frames so
from the you know from the secrets here
the temporal we have compared with the
traditional image style transfer and no
or compared with our proposed method the
images traditional image star transfer
command maintains the consistencies so
the circles and the bond boxes there you
can see that the style changes the
changes significantly but for our video
part it can maintain a good consistency
so this will prevent it will eliminate
the chattering chatting the flickering
artifacts in the videos okay so this is
the Memphis no the main network of our
video star transfer and the first part
is a style sterilized in network this is
very traditional and we have a intro
encoder decoder encoder decoder style
style and we have the encoders and we
ski we connected with fives the rest
night's rest blocks and then the
decoders and after that we realize the
lost networks two computers a stylized
Network and the content lost Network and
also the the temporal loss so with this
loss is the well design we can we can
train the networks to make the network
okay preserve the content and as well as
the introducer style and the most
important can preserve the consistency
between our choice on the frames okay so
for these are special training we have
the two frame coordinator training so it
means that we input the adjacent to
firms into the network and then you try
the designers obsessive specific design
Allah
function to join the network and also
another another advantage is that we do
not need to computer optical flow
information on the on the fly so it
means that we can well we can well make
the Magnum we can well max the inference
very fast because we do not need to
compute computer the optic flow normally
the optical is the most complicated part
in video parts okay
and I thing is that because we are you
know this is name instant message this
is instant message a PPS so the person's
will share therefore their pictures in
with the with the with their friends so
the pictures may be taking in and the
different conditions for this case we
want to handle the yeah makes the image
quality enhanced enhanced for the
low-light images so we have if you take
an image in the low light you can now
you cannot define you cannot find the
age of the content and also the the
color you cannot find you cannot take
the right colors so we proposed a method
to enhance the low-light images and we
have the image here and with Mecca
displayed to the original video for
remade part and also the edge part so
because the aji the mostess talent to
the human perception so for the low
lighting in low light input original
part which we use in critical style to
encoded image and decode image cats are
in low results and also for the edge
part will utilize also something like
the encoder decoder and afterwards we
have the skipped layer and a ways the
iron style
to catch the edge information then paste
this to the content information and a as
and also the edge information will
combine them a together then to have a
enhanced quality of the images and then
we catch some perceptual losses and also
other adverse or losses to enhance the
quality of the image okay this is some
results and we have the the first zero
is a low-light images that were provided
and we use the our networking how we can
well Rick we recover the content of the
image and also the colors can be well
preserved
okay so this is this is one part of we
can share the images and improve the
image quality and the next step the next
work is a mobile pose estimation
actually for the post estimation has
been well to study they either have been
well studied but for the mobile part if
you will need to perform the network
compression and also Mac hated to detect
the scattering the other joints very
accurately
so in this means this part when mostly
focusing on the network compression and
the network returning okay so they we
ship to the network from the PCs to the
mobile wires and we can perform the
detection of the person in the market
persons and also for some front and back
bone and something like and also
instances choose a to the colors of
their closest and as they see the demos
here and the first the lefty I think
that is EC maybe for the projection part
so this is not for real time and this is
the 22 key points for the joints of the
persons and the under the laptop wha is
a we consider to detect the hand because
the monster hand the hand detection will
will facilitate our you know the touch
based interaction with the with the
phones all the TVs okay and also for our
mobile post estimation we have some you
can see that for this one we we are Rob
to the full or half body half body half
body that conclusions on the half bodies
and also we are we are able to perform a
single or multiple persons and also we
are you know we are insensitive to the
dressing colors or the other other
dressings and also we are robust to to
the front and back even from the front
and that we have detected the joints and
the under the under the informations of
the scallops and also we have already
deployed this to mix into mobile queue
and for this one this is the left the
right one is a detector of my person of
the scanners and left why is that we
have the skeletons and we can have a
dancing machine so you can for
you know the guidance and the performed
advances and then they say that very
interesting to you know interact with
the films are interactive with the TVs
yeah so you can with this one we can
find the you know with the this oppose
direction contractor can match your
positions with design the other
specified actions okay so this is a work
on the post estimation okay and on topic
either very very interesting topic
either for the video attractive
attractiveness
now the because for we have that instant
video so we have a lot of a lot of video
dramas or a lot of TV series uploaded on
the website so we want to find whether
the users is interested in to some part
of the videos so we would like to
examine whether we can predict the video
attractiveness from the only the visual
information or the other informations so
for this one we have the video input and
we have sorry we have the video input
and also also is associated with the
audio input and we would like to predict
its attractiveness and the grant choose
is the orange line and the predict voice
is pretty ones either either blue line
actually for this actual attractive it
is very hard to get to the ground truth
data so we utilize the muse because this
is a transom video have a lot of
registrate errs so there are many many
of you many many viewers at this time so
for each of these is this each of these
values in each points it means that at
this specific time how many person have
already have already watched this video
sequence and this is specific time so
the in the statistically the larger of
the number it means that there are many
members there are a lot of large number
of person watch this video at this
moment so this moment it should be the
much more attractive much more
attractive attractive than the other
with smaller values so we we utilize
this video as the attractiveness
conscious value okay so for this chart
Scott we build a large largest large
scale that such we have one cell about
one of the
and they in total about seven eight
hours and they're in we consist of
twenty two hundred and seventy episodes
of American dramas and also certainly
true career dramas and also seven
episodes of Chinese drummers so we have
this one we consider diverse of types
and we have also movie the new
information that we can you know start a
meki to the robusta to the video
attractive star study and the process is
statistical information of our data set
and the this is the number of the
episodes and this is number of the views
attracting the views and in the law was
you know look okay
and also besides of the views actually
for because this is for the transom
video your father is a video platform
you will have some of the other metadata
or some other user engagement
Reformation the ad my engagement
information will crowd is start of it is
the start of the forward and the end of
the forward the start of the backward
and the start of the end of the backward
and also have sample it's quiz and the
balloon the number of double screens and
the likes of the pollen squeeze and also
we have the the the forward skips and
the first the word faster we were ruined
skips so with these ones we can get
another more information about the user
engagements with the videos with these
user engagements of videos you can kind
of more in for more detailed information
about the video attract news and we can
based on these engagements to analysis
more alanis more about the human
behaviors okay
as we mentioned before we would like to
make a prediction about attracted from
the audio and the video or audio
information and the visual information
so for these two different modalities
because we have a world apart and all
operation part so we before we propose
three different of furious strategy why
is in the low level and away in the
middle bear and the way in the high
level and they see that three strong
this industry architecture of the
heart and we have also each part of it
before we utilize we perform a contact
skating here okay
so based on this this architectural we
perform the prediction and we we have
the we also propose the three about
three criteria to evaluate whether we
can actually perform the a accurate
prediction so we have we have the four
matrix and then we'll compare with
different visual representation from
which G to inception to rest last night
and the for the other part will compare
with M FCC and and also the one that
part so we can see that you consider all
the audio features and video feature
together we can get a better result and
better results but if we kind me sample
the middle level high level and a lot of
fuel strategy together we can get to the
best performance so another thing is
that from nothing imagine to note that
either we have the if we have the
engagements the inkatha means that is
the behavior of the users so we can if
we can cut his engagement so we can make
a very I could bury accurate a
prediction on the video attract noticed
because if they like it it will wash it
and otherwise they will leave this leave
these videos so the in the human
engagements is the most important part
in the indicator the indicator of the
video attract noise okay so this is for
the video attracting starting and also
we study we make some study on the video
classification and as I mentioned before
the mention about Lisa before the
moments are the moments in time the
three main seconds of the video test
that it also about video classifications
right and now now before that they are
the arch there there's a benchmark that
sat on the UCF 1 0 1 so we perform for
this part will perform the to stream we
utilize that to stream say ends on the
on the video classification and the one
stream is describes the content and one
stream it describes the optical
information optical flow which means
that motion information between our
Johnson the frames and
we propose a principled back propagation
propagation that we forward other
snippers so the forwarding formation can
capture all the information of the
videos and but for the backward will
perform as selectively to backward only
a selected number of snipers
niklas so one info when one one benefits
is that from this efficient fabrication
we can get we can perform official
training and another benefit is that we
can also perform the snipers in
different skills to characterize the
motion the different motion information
in the videos okay this is our results
and for this test set the people not
here and out even at achieved the top
one error rate is about only 8.6
percentage so this is slow this is
smaller than the other competitive
models okay also for the video
classifications we will participate in
the YouTube YouTube 8,000,000 challenge
here and the for the YouTube 8 million
challenges here they only provided the
weight of the features for the visual
features and the audio features so we
work on the audio and the video feature
to perform the video classification and
we for these things that we perform a to
two-level cascading winding in the video
level so the beta level where averages
the all the frames together to get to
the video representation and we propose
a multi fueling layer here as typically
here and the them pop we follow
classifiers which has a mixed mixture of
experts and a global accuracy precision
it about is only 0.8 - okay
and also we performed the frame level
classification in the forum through a
level class it is very intuitive to have
the Alice TM and all that you are you to
model the sequential data so for the
video the video features this is also
can be viewed as a sequential data see
we so we utilize the up a direction or
our stem and year old and the GRU and
also we consider different different
emotions information so we perform a
multi scale
so for you to scale we perform our we
perform a direction by directional GRU
or our stem and the Jaypee here the
globe the global average precision is
zero point zero point eighty three and
if we consider the video level part and
the frame lab of heart together we can
get the Jaypee is the zero point eight
four and we achieved about to the force
positions number four the fourth
positions over the six hundred sixty
100's emissions okay so this is about
the video and email and a video analysis
okay afterwards I will ensure that I
will afterwards I will give an
instruction about some work that we have
done on the learn on the understanding
one part is the image understanding here
and the image understanding this is a
very difficult part because we you may
understand the image caption and image
can be a very difficult part because
we're not only to understand the image
content but also we need to learn the
language the properties or the behavior
of the language compositions and also we
need to perform a Amati motio
interactions between the image and the
sentence system okay so for this one
here we also utilize our traditional
something like that our traditional
architecture for the image we utilize
the images and to encode the information
and the weak max we get the image
representation in the combo wines and in
the localized further if we have a thing
here if I have a if you have familiar
with singing for the last at the for the
connect layer this is a global
representation and the folder in the
media convolution layers this is a
global this is the local representations
so for each image images saying we can
get the we can get the image global and
local representations and with this
represent if we have different things
such as a inception and ResNet or the
bgg we have different things we will
have multiple multiple representation of
the image for each group for each side
we have a global representation and a
local representation and with these
different representations we can perform
a multi stage attention and the multi
stage acum multi stage attention can
first summarize the information from
different encoders such as the rest not
in separate reception we've before and
also the bgg so we can we can example
this represent and together and also Max
is the represented to interact with each
other and for the attention part so they
can broadcast their their information to
the other encoder tune to let the other
Hoda know whether what information has
been already considered for the
generation part okay if you have
afterwards with will perform the multi
stage attention then we utilize another
ticketed another another decoder to
decode these representations to
sentences the decoder normally we can
utilize and now iron and the L stem and
Jo is the most effective arms so we have
here we utilize that our stem so we have
different we have the image in coda
cattle representation and we have the
decoder to decode a representation into
a sentence okay so this is first this is
this PA firstly this turkey is this task
is you need to consider the information
of the content in the email in the image
and also integrate with the sentences to
make it to focus on the each object
during the generation of each words such
as for the persons you need to pay
attention to the object of the the
person need to pay attention to the
local region or the persons and then
generate your words and I've only the
heels you need to pay attention to the
local region of the image and then
generates the words here okay so for
these things we propose a based on our
multi stage attention we have a
performer you know we have some meat our
adults on the mattress of the cocoa
challenge here this
most I think that is the most most
influenceable influence that fact the
image captioning for each image it will
each image is accompanied with five
sentences and there are about about
100,000 images and for each images as it
is come accompanied with five sentences
so I think that appeared the pear date
has four imagery and a centipede theater
it is about six hundred thousand peers
okay based on this data you can perform
the you can perform you can perform you
can promote training of the the of your
model and less damage that results of
the test data on the website and the for
this website we have we have several
criteria to evaluate results and for the
resulting has see that for this is the
blue and the blue blue one blue two blue
three blue for and also we have the
meter raj and a cider CID are listed
over for the CIDR this is the most
specifically designed for evaluators or
quality of the image captioning okay so
so this will fall for this we can see
that for the c5 and the c40 we can
achieve all four all the metrics we
achieve the top one top well results and
compared to the other
are there other models here okay
also we also we have transformed we have
we have a collector a mother Chinese
data set we have a image here and also
we have the imager and it's accompanied
our Chinese sentences and we train the
models and also we deployed we have
released the results and we the way we
we build a latest program in we chat so
you can experience it if you have the
which have here ok this is a Chinese for
integrant image recognition okay so for
this image it for the Chinese it is give
a brief instruction wery good
disclosure about the content of the
image okay and
for this thing if we have the image
captioning the readouts will give an
image and I gave you sentences to
describe the content page we can perform
first the most restrictive way it is a
perform the image description another is
that we have these sentences that we can
perform the image retrieval and also as
well as the image recommendations and
also for the visual dialogues and the
most important saying if you have the
image under the content that these
questions will help the visually
impaired and impaired the email person
to read or to see the images okay so
this is a work on image captioning and
afterwards the last work that I'm going
to introduce is the natural language of
video localization they see the also
other challenge at have changnesia her
school want to use utilize a language we
give a we tries we're giving a untrimmed
a video and a natural language
description the girl we would like to
look like a segment in the video which
correspondent to the given natural
language a description it means that if
you will if we have a sorry if we have a
very long video services and we have a
sentence that describes such as a woman
rails
keep a kite backing in forward herself
we would like to localize these centers
in the videos so this is the very same
as the image captioning it is a very
challenge because first we need to
understand the language under the next
we need to understand the video
sequester but for the video sequester
understand is even challenger the images
because the temporal we need to not only
consider the image account the spatial
content of the image but also we need to
consider the temporal relationship
between the adjacent frames so we
perform we propose a single stream a
single stream a natural language video
local sestra network for this part we
have the video sorry we have the videos
and I will have a sentence that would
perform frame by word interactions or
matrix here all matching serial is
matching matching performance matching
between the
and the video then we have with these
matching behaviors we perform temporal
proposals and they have a different
anchors then we'll have different scores
with these single-stream processes we
can efficiently localize the sentences
in the video sequences okay and this is
some results of our this is summer
results of our proposed masters and they
see the videos and the DC have a
sentence a man in a red shirt claps his
hand and the great wines you know
crunches and the green one is we utilize
the vgg 16 as the image as the encoder
and for the blue ones is we utilize the
inception before as a encoder and the
yellow ones we utilize the c3d at the
encoder so you can see that if we you
know the vgg 16 and inception v4 we can
get a reasonable accurate result I'm
sure for this for this specific trust we
up from all the competitor models on
this especially the tasks and for this
that's that before this the the camera
will lose out to show where the what-for
is coming from so this can you can see
that the folder for the for the Furion
we fear in the inception before and
optic flow we can get the accurate
prediction on this on this example okay
wait another besides we examine we
examine the frame and the frame by word
attentions here and for this sentence
what for for this and for this and and
what for in forest for they say you can
see that for this all video sequences in
the forest
the first is appeared over all frames so
the attention Mario's
will be attentive will be triggered
equally but for this for this woful only
appearing in the first first of frame so
it won't have this burials here ok and
the same observation can be of can be
observed from this to give examples okay
so this is the lots of works that I
introduced about a computer vision meets
with social network actually besides
that in our lab we not only I would not
only do the work uncommon variant but
also we have some of the other works on
the AI projects the most improper one of
the Muslim part of our project is the
air + house and we would like to deploys
or utilize the air technology to make
the healthcare and also the first the
healthcare the first day is that we
would like to UT the air tagging or deep
learning tomorrow to analysis the
medical images and them to detect to
helps the the to helps the doctors to
make the room to help the detection to
make the diagnosis and the forces for
this is specific for these specific
cancers such as a lung cancer screens
about for this recognition rate
Yaba is over 98 percentage and also in
the future we would like to would you
like to do perform a computer editor
diagnosis and we have somewhat just
scripts about the discretion of the
patients and also we have some medical
images about the passions and would like
to have the doctor to attack max the
diagnosis and also even in the future we
have to help the doctor to design the
treatment about some the disease okay
another important topic is a again
because the game because tension the
game is large the number one game
company in the of the world so we would
like to utilize the AI technology to
involved to be multiply involved in the
game may be the design the playing or
something like that to make the game to
be more interesting and more more
interesting to the user to the players
ok so I will give a brief summary here
and the first that I will give an
introduction about our talk computer
ramiz social networks and we introduced
some some work that we have done in
testing a lab from the research product
and something related to image a video
processing understanding and analysis
something like that and also we have I
have introduced about some when our
several our employment projects a
applies the ax the ax maybe house gain
or in the future some robotics or
something like that okay so this is the
another introduc my lecture okay thank
you
[Applause]